hey this is precious hi Walker in this
video I'm going to teach you a trick
which fools many people start by taking
a rectangular strip of paper and drawing
thirteen straight black lines you can
follow along with me if you have a
rectangular strip of paper now very
carefully cut the shape diagonally
across this line it goes from the top of
the first line to the bottom of the last
line once you make the cut you'll have
two pieces of paper now slide the upper
piece along the diagonal up and to the
left so that exactly lines up you now
have a new shape which has only 12 lines
the original shape has 13 lines so
clearly you have shown that 13 lines
equal 12 lines so 13 is equal to 12 all
we did was rearrange the same lines the
question is how did one line just vanish
where did the missing line go now when
you show this many people know that
something is amiss but very few people
can explain exactly what's going on can
you figure it out give this problem a
try and when you're ready keep watching
the video for the solution
so I'm telling you the new shape has 12
lines and the original shape had one
extra line with 13 lines and it appears
that all of the lines are of the same
length but that in fact is the issue the
missing line is an illusion the new
shape has 12 lines but they are longer
lines each line is longer by 1 12
compares to the original shape in other
words the missing line length is
distributed evenly into each of the new
lines the reason you can't see this is
because the twelve lines and the 13
lines look like they're the same length
but if you measure carefully you'll
actually see that these twelve lines are
longer so we'll focus on just one of
these lines now let's compare it in
length to the original shape you can see
that it's just a little bit longer it's
one 12 longer compared to the original
line so this illusion works because you
have so many lines and you're only
changing the length by very little if
you were to do this with only four lines
you'd actually be able to see that the
lines are longer but that's the reason
this illusion works did you figure it
out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math you can catch me on my
blog mind your decisions that you can
follow on Facebook Google+ and patreon
you can catch me on social media at
Parker and if you like this video please
check out my books there are links in
the video description